[Music]
joining me today is a guy who doesn't
like Nazis or anti feh and is also the
host of the dogma debate podcast David
Smalley finally welcome to the room
thanks for having me I appreciate it
yeah we've been trying to make this
happen for a couple months yeah you were
writing here on your motorcycle yeah you
burned your finger remember my first
guest I think to be in physical pain I
put some people through mental pain but
I think you're my first injured getting
yeah it's uh it's interesting it was a
little warmer today than I thought it
was gonna be and I pulled over to take
my jacket off and roll it up and I'll
try to stuff it into the saddlebag and
burned my finger on my own exhaust so
right there your your viewers will know
my level of intelligence there's some
sort of metaphor there you burned your
fingers on your own exhaust there's
something there there's something deep
yeah and and it kind of reminds me of on
my way to interview Richard Dawkins for
my podcast yeah I had a motorcycle
accident like someone pulled out in
front of me and I slammed into him on
the way I was still I'm still made it
and did the interview but yeah there's
something going on any time I'm gonna go
do something that I really enjoy doing
something's trying to stop yeah what's
going on there nice someone upstairs
looking at you judging you no not that
no chance I think we'll get into that
we'll get into that a little bit how
long you been doing the motorcycle thing
Oh almost two years now yeah I mean I
rode their bikes for seven eight years
as a kid I actually wrote a dirt bike
before I could ride a bicycle my dad
taught me to ride a to balance on two
wheels on a on a motorcycle so I made
you an atheist right there
no reading the Bible is what made me an
atheist yeah all right so let's start
there so for people who don't know you
at all so you host a show called Dogma
debate I've been a guest on the show we
do very sort of similar thing you
actually are one of the people that I
think is trying to get some answers
you're not trying to be a judgmental
prick that's how's that for a compliment
yeah thank you that's pretty much the
greatest compliment I can nowadays it is
right
no that's that's what I've done yeah
you're trying to explore some things and
you're willing to talk to people you
agree with and disagree with and all
that stuff but your backstory is pretty
interesting because because you are an
atheist now but you grew up as an
evangelical Christian it was in the
music men talk about it yeah I was in
the music ministry I was a drummer
usually for all-black gospel churches
now if you've never listened to that
music you've you're missing out I still
love it I still enjoy it the the the
all-black choirs oh man there's
something about it I mean it's uplifting
it's awesome that the message is
positive there's a lot of fun there
the music's more like a blues and funky
jazz oriented sort of style what I did
play a few times for the white churches
it was so boring they didn't want me to
use regular sticks they wanted me to use
the little nylon brushes no the the
black churches let me go all out they
had a you know bass guitarist and
keyboard and those are some of the the
greatest times of my life I was a part
of the ministry and then my pastor had
me go door knocking you know and to tell
people about Jesus Christ and I'm on my
mission doing this I say mission I
wasn't Mormon but I was on my mission of
winning souls and I knocked on this
lady's door and I said I'd like to talk
to you but our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ and she said honey you need Jesus
and slam the door in my face and
standing there staring at her door I
thought what if she's right what if she
has the right version of Jesus and I'm
walking around this neighborhood telling
people something that's not true yeah
how old were you at this point I was
about 17 16 somewhere around there and
so maybe 15 maybe a little younger and I
remember thinking what if I'm leading
people away from Christ and so you know
it's actually started when I was
baptized I thought I'm not good enough
to be a Christian I'd better figure this
stuff out like they've given me the
uniform and sent me out on the field and
I don't know any of the plays I don't
know what we're doing I don't know if I
have the truth and so I started thinking
how do I know my little small town in
Texas that church
we're the ones going to heaven and
everyone else has it wrong yeah how do I
know right and what if that lady's right
what if what if what if I need Jesus and
she has the right version so I thought
you know what there's a lot of confusion
around this
I want to get so close to God that I can
solve these problems I want to make sure
I can I can lead people the right way
and so I started literally reading the
Bible cover-to-cover I talked with
theology professors I talked with
pastors I talked with friends who were
Christians and I got so close I saw that
there wasn't one and that this book is
very much left up to interpretation and
then I started sort of going all these
people who claim to believe have they
asked these questions how do they know
they have the right version of Jesus and
it was a 14-year journey for me this was
not you know oh I had a traumatic event
in my life so I threw at my aunts and
said God why do you I didn't have a
lieutenant day in moment no no I was
like screw you right it was much more of
an intentional process of I want to know
God I want to be close to God I didn't
feel good enough to be a Christian why
you on a boat in Louisiana during the
storm we could get you to have a
lieutenant Dan Roman maybe so maybe
maybe so I'll probably cursing it I
don't know Thor in that moment right so
it's interesting though because your
evolution out of religion was through
reading religious texts where I think a
lot of people have a sort of leap of
faith moment but rarely does that have
to do with reading text you know to me
the people that are even becoming more
religious they have that leap of faith
whatever that personal experience is for
them but I wonder how many people
actually read the full text and go one
way or the other
yeah I think I think meaning that you
were informed about what you were doing
and I think a lot of people just kind of
check out either way they make a
decision without necessarily reading
everything I think most atheists that
I've talked to and I've had my show for
almost six years I've talked with tons
of atheists although I try to make my
show mostly about talking with believers
and people who I would fundamentally
disagree with but I would say most
people who get into the faith do it
because of a mentor in their lives
there's some pastor or a preacher or
some charismatic leader who will use a
Bible verse and say here's a teachable
moment and they use that Bible verse and
then they talk about it or do a sermon
on it in some way that you leave there
feeling oh wow that
that was speaking directly to me well
the reason you feel that it's not
because the Bible itself was speaking
directly to you it's because the the
charismatic trained preacher used that
Bible verse as a motivational speech
ignition and so that's what it really
turns into so whenever you leave Church
feeling good it's it's on purpose but if
you go back and read all of the verses
especially the ones the preachers skip
over right that's where you start to go
await a minute that doesn't sound like
this loving God I thought I was
worshiping so that's where it started to
break down I think people will convert
into religion for mostly emotional
reasons but I would say for the most
part people who leave the faith do so
informed as I did I think they start
looking into it and going this doesn't
add up to this is there a scientific
answer for what I used to think was
metaphysical and then they get informed
in science and then go wait a minute
it's not that I don't like God it's that
God is irrelevant we don't need God in
order to answer a lot of these questions
and I don't know it's still okay I
normally don't offer my guests a guest
in the middle of the show but have you
had Andrew clay been on by anything I
have not so I'm gonna connect you with
Andrew Clavin he's a really interesting
guy born Jewish then was an atheist most
of his life and then became Christian
and talk so I think you'd have a senior
in lacs here in LA he's multiple-time
guest on the Rubin report and I'm gonna
kick him over to you I usually do more
politics with him so I think and I've
done some of that but I think you know I
think you'll dig it so when you when you
had this awakening so to speak can
people describe it as an awakening if
it's opening - I'm solid a yeah yeah I'm
fine so when you had that awakening had
the family take it like what was it like
for you first like were you like oh man
but was I following a lie you know you
know at first I was reading online and I
found my first atheist online and it was
Frank Ziegler for people who don't know
who he is look him up he said he speaks
a million languages the guy's brilliant
he's he's awesome and he he was doing a
radio debate this was a transcript from
a radio debate in 1989 and it was with a
Christian geologist and he's an atheist
geologist and they were debating Noah's
Flood this idea that there was actually
a real flood and he said something is so
funny there's something so small
he asked the guy I was reading the
transcript because this was in early
2000 or late 90s that I was reading this
was at least 10 years old he asked the
guy he said why did God only save the
land animals in the flood and the
Christian geologists had no answer for
it and then Frank said well you do
realize that that amount of fresh water
falling into the oceans would have
diluted the pH levels to the point that
marine life would have died too
so why didn't God tell us to save the
marine life as well and he said unless
of course the entire story is fabricated
and those people didn't know the
difference between ocean water and rain
water and that I just thought how come
no one's ever thought of this and so
that was like an aha moment for me and I
just went it was kind of like a boy
raised by wolves seeing his first human
going oh that's what I am that's why
none of this stuff makes sense to me
that's why I can't lick my own privates
I don't mind my body doesn't work that
way you know and so you try you could
try and then some talented people I'm
sure can accomplish it but the average
person can't yeah and so that you know
that's what I'm like that was my mom I
felt relieved I wasn't scared I wasn't
angry I finally just felt I'm not alone
there are other people out there that
question this stuff and so when I first
told my mom I never said I'm an atheist
I said I'm not a Christian anymore I
just casually told her over the phone
and she was like well why not and I said
I've just been reading a lot of the
Bible have you read this verse have you
read that she's like no I never read
that I never read that no okay and I
just left it at that and she didn't
offer a lot of pushback and I'm one of
the lucky ones
some people get thrown out of their
homes their college education cutoff
there they're not allowed to talk to
their families anymore you know Leah
Remini is doing this thing on
Scientology where people are literally
cut off from their families Jehovah's
Witnesses are very similar they won't
let you talk to people outside of the
cult it's it's really you know divisive
and so when my mom started to complain
about how churches were doing this I
knew the Bible very well and I just said
mom listen in the Bible in Matthew 10:34
Jesus says do not think that I came to
bring peace on earth I did not come to
bring peace I came to bring division to
set a man against his father a daughter
against her mother a man's enemies will
be those in his own household I said so
regardless of what denomination one
Jesus is successful at dividing families
and we have this commandment you shall
honor your father and mother Luke 14:26
says if you don't hate your mom and dad
you can't be my disciple so he was a
cult leader leading people away from
their families just like Jehovah's
Witnesses just like David Miscavige with
with Scientology they're leading people
away from their families and trying to
divide and I'm more about bringing
people together with humanism than
dividing based on religion yeah it's so
interesting too because although I
haven't read all three of them cover to
cover the New Testament is actually I'm
pretty sure it's by far the most
peaceful of the big three right of the
Old Testament the Quran and the New
Testament the New Testaments probably
the most peaceful but yet they're still
reading out yeah well there's still
quite a bit of horrible things in there
Romans 1:26 through 32 still says gays
are worthy of death and anyone who
supports gays are worthy of death this
is New Testament it mentions Ephesians
says slaves obey your earthly masters so
we still have an approval of slavery in
the New Testament and the New Testament
is also where Jesus is saying if you
don't hate people you can't follow me if
you don't have a sword sell your cloak
and buy one it's he's very much a
violent cult leader you know what I mean
so the New Testament does have some you
know the greatest commandment of all
love your neighbor as yourself
love your enemy feed your enemy but
that's ones contradictory to a lot of
the other verses in there so when you
talk about this stuff now you know that
my audience is pretty much all over the
spiritual matter the the secular map the
political map all of that really I
thought you were a conservative show
yeah in furn all right maniac all right
Nazi sympathizing conservative shield
that's what I read well I'm pretty sure
we're in some of the same knot are you
these days are you telling me that
there's stuff on the internet that's not
true can you believe that I don't
believe it it's not I can really nuts so
my audience though is all over the place
in every way and that and I love it
you know because sometimes people say
y'all have Reubens selling out for these
people are that people I'm like I
literally completely the truth I would
not even know which way to sell out
trying to which I'm not trying to
obviously but I mention this because
what I think is interesting is that I
have a lot of people that are
and conservatives that email me and
they'll say I they'll just be like you
know I never heard a liberal that was
sort of tolerant of us because I do try
to be tolerant of you know I've had
Christian conservatives on the show and
I I try to be as tolerant of anyone as
they will be of me it's it's a two-way
street as sure so when when my audience
that's a Christian conservative out
there is listening to this they're gonna
be on their back heels obviously here in
some of that stuff so how do you go
about bridging that divide I bridge that
with questions I don't necessarily want
to come at you and say here's everything
wrong with your religion let me just
talk directly to them for a moment I'll
tell them everything that you love about
your religion I love that too the the
peace the helping the less fortunate
the loving your neighbor the accepting
everybody a lot of people think that
when I say I'm an atheist or if I'm
arguing against Christianity that that's
what I'm trying to take from you I'm not
trying to take that I want you to
embrace that I love that too more than
likely the things that I dislike about
your religion are things that you're not
aware of that that live within your
religion things that are buried within
your holy book that you would make you
uncomfortable I just bring it to the
surface and say how do you reconcile a
loving God with this with the story of
Jobe with we just did a whole podcast on
the story of Java what am i what am i I
have have this quite a few now Christian
followers on patreon who or follow me on
Twitter who support me on patreon and
they they want to come on the show and
have discussions and so I ask questions
and bring things to light to say how do
you how do you worship a God that said
slavery was okay and they'll go out that
was indentured servitude okay except
that's not so great dude but well yeah
that that's in there but there's another
part in there in Leviticus I think it's
25 44 through 46 that specifically says
you can buy Hebrew slaves from among you
you can pass them down to your children
you can own them forever as property
that's not indentured servitude that's
slavery it talks about how often you can
beat your slaves so what I do is how I
bridge the gap is I ask the question how
do you walk around day to day being a
good person and then justify horrific
actions to me that's the embodiment of
evil
you said what is evil you're an atheist
now you have no basis for morality yeah
well hold on we do have human harm we do
have human for flourishing these are
facts of reality the mechanism by which
to judge that I would say is John Rawls
veil of ignorance put yourself behind
the veil to remove your own bias and
decide it should rape be okay
are you the victim are you the rapist
should poverty be okay are you the one
in poverty or are you the billionaire
you know you can you can look at it and
go if I'm behind the veil of ignorance
and don't know what I'm gonna be on the
other side then you can make an unbiased
objective call on it and so whenever I
try to remove that piece of it try to
remove the the bias from it it really
comes down to me going there was a god
at one point that said slavery was okay
that in 1st Samuel 15-3 told Saul to go
kill infants he said go kill the babies
the nursing infants go kill them how do
you as a good person say I can't wait to
get to heaven and worship that dude how
do you reconcile that how do you so in
some ways do you think it almost doesn't
matter what's in the text specifically
it's only what people act on so for in
other words there's good you know for
however many Jews that are out there
there's not that many that believe in a
literal interpretation of the Bible
there are probably less Christians right
now that believe in a literal
interpretation than maybe twenty years
ago right I think it's a little bit
different right now with Islam and
Muslims just from just from those gross
and racist pupils that there are people
there is a disproportionate amount of
people but obviously not all and
obviously not most right and all that
some better believing in a literal
interpretation so in some ways they can
all have bad things but it's really
about how the people act not it right
like because we all have those things
where we take sort of because they also
vote they also teach their children that
you know demons are watching them at
night and there's this huge chess game
of struggle between good and evil and
that if you do something bad the devil
made me do it and if you do something
good God gets the credit I think there
are things that are mental child abuse
at some level if you're telling a child
that a devil and a Satan is watching
them and interacting in their lives
you're inducing a mild form of psychosis
telling this child that there's this
magical demonic creature participating
in their lives and
you're really distorting their view of
reality and also if you're teaching a
child you know that the earth is 6,000
years old and there was a giant flood
and we don't have geological evidence
for any of this you're making it very
difficult for when he gets in seventh
grade and they go yeah all animals are
connected through biological evolution
you're stunting his educational growth
and we need those kids we need those
kids as the engineers of the future so
it's not just about the behaviors I
think it's also about I think what what
you believe still matters because we
live in the same world yeah you said all
that I think so yeah probably
that's pretty good maybe so let's do
some definitions just some basic
definitions of things because I think
when people talk about this I know
there's always confusion over atheism
agnosticism and the rest of it so let's
just do what what does atheism mean to
you
a lack of a theism you don't have a
belief in a theology you don't have a
belief in a in a deity yeah
and what is it agnosticism mean to you
well agnosticism I would ask an agnostic
what God do you believe in and they're
gonna say I don't have a belief in a God
well congratulations you're an atheist
too I think every most I would say yeah
it's hard for me to say every because I
don't speak in absolutes yeah but I
would say the vast majority of atheists
it would technically be agnostic
atheists because agnostic deals with
knowledge do you have all the knowledge
or are you without some knowledge I'm
without some knowledge are you a little
bit my desk I'm like I did not know
there you go so to some degree you're
agnostic and I'm agnostic yeah do you
have a God you believe in well no I I
might say there's a possibility with
enough evidence I'm willing to believe
anything if there's enough evidence
there why not
we're always willing to change my mind
so I mean I'm I'm an agnostic who says I
don't know but when it comes to theism I
don't have it to use am I believe in I'm
a I'm a theist I don't have one yeah so
an agnostic atheist if someone said
that's what Smalley is you could accept
that sure right it's just yeah it
doesn't it doesn't matter yeah and I
know I know your feelings on all the
labels and we're gonna get to some of
the political labels anyway but the
reason I mentioned this is because so so
Peter Burgos in have you had SP been on
your show I have okay so all right Pete
I think originally connected us
okay so pizza a great guy and and I
think he basically takes that same
approach to agnostic atheism but I don't
know if you happen to see this so you
know I went off the grid for August and
when I did this video when I came back I
did a live stream and someone just you
know I was just reading questions
questions you're just live coming in and
someone asked me something about my
atheism yes and basically I basically I
said that while I was away and I had had
some time I was working on my book and I
took a little time off and I wasn't
looking at computers and phones and all
this stuff but something hit me that I
didn't feel that the the word atheist
was quite appropriate to me anymore not
that I believe in some magical thing
that I can't prove I simply do not I
never have and I don't but that I did
have moments of sort of peace over the
course of this thirty days where I felt
I just had this feeling of there could
be something else out there and I don't
want to rule that out now I don't think
that's any different from anything that
you just said there in any way but I did
get a lot of atheist pissed at me I mean
there were a lot of people really penny
was by the way it was a very flip I was
just reading the questions in front of
me I was at oh I wasn't prepared I just
said something off the top of my head
and I thought man I wish you guys could
be as tolerant as you often say you are
yeah by the time I by the time they got
to me it was a tweet that said your
buddy Dave Rubin just joined some cult
or something like you were now you were
I didn't realize you had joined a church
and I think they said Tarko Carlson was
secretly a KKK members oh yeah and so I
sent you that text and was like I had no
idea
Tucker removes his hood to do a show and
you were now a church leader I didn't
know that was connected to Matt and
second comment that's when I came from
and they sent me that and then I said do
you have evidence of this they sent me
that clip and I went that's not evidence
of him renouncing atheism yeah but on
that what did you think and you are
welcome to ask me anything yeah my
question is yeah you being open to
something being out there just means
you're reasonable means you're open to
evidence that doesn't mean you now have
a belief in a theism right so that's
still an atheist so why wouldn't the
word atheist still represent so all I
think I think really what I was trying
to say in that moment was that I that I
think there's an association with the
word you know I mean not I understand
what the literal definition
of atheist is but I think that there's
an association with the word that I
don't know that I need that thrown on to
me we all get these labels thrown onto
us all the time and I think that that
can often shut down conversations
unfortunately having nothing to do with
what you actually really believe yeah
and I just felt that like let's put it
this way if if somebody was doing a talk
show and they wanted to bring on an
atheist to really talk about atheism I
actually think you would be a much
better advocate for that then I would be
and that's really that's really all that
I meant that I I'm just giving room for
some other stuff to be out there and I
know again that's not any that's not in
conflict with anything you've just said
I get that I mean I you know when I meet
someone for the first time if it's my
daughter's friends or someone in the
community that I'm going to interact
with I'm an atheist do that but because
I know how that can make them a little
uh so I do let them get to know me and
if they ask me about church I'll say
we're not religious or I'll throw
something out there like that
although out here in LA it's way
different than saying that into you know
pretty religious over there so but I'll
say that I'll tend to hold off sometimes
but a public figure like yourself where
people already knew that you you don't
have a God belief I think more of us
should embrace the term yeah and so and
sort of help normalize it so that it's
not something that's a bad word you know
so when my daughter's 13 when she's 17
and gets tries to get a job at you know
jack-in-the-box and they say they're
asking her questions and she mentions
she's an atheist I wanted to not I want
it to be as so ya know what and I and
you also don't collect stamps what's
your point
why are you who cares that's what we're
hoping for as a as a secular activists I
want to work myself out of a job and I
want to get more into politics and I
want to get more into you know other
dogmas out there I called my show Dogma
debate for that reason there I didn't
pigeon-holed it to atheism because
atheists have Dogma to let's let's hash
that out Democrats have plenty of dogma
Republicans have Dogma yeah let's hash
those things out well that that's the
funny part to me because I think I saw a
little of that atheist dogma right there
so again I it was a very flipped comment
I made something I wasn't really
prepared or even had put much thought
into talk about publicly
just reading it live and just the amount
of anger and again it's Twitter and we
can't judge reality and odor and all
that but just the amount of people that
were so angry that clipped it and then
we're saying you he's a sellout and all
this stuff and it's like guys all I was
really saying was that I want there to
be a little space for me to to play in
another era another intellectual area
another spiritual area think about that
means sam harris talks about
spiritualism and he's one of the most
famed i read the book in the world the
books right there yeah and where is it
there it is waking up right there rise
to spirituality without religion by an
atheist yeah so the fact that you want
most Buddhists are atheist they don't
have a Godhead they worship but they're
very religious you can be spiritual you
can be religious without having a
Godhead that you believe in you're still
an atheist you're just like what atheist
has become online don't associate me
with that I think maybe that is a and
you're also tying in a lot of
regressives are atheists but the vast
majority of atheists are reasonable
liberals like you and I who are like I'm
a liberal and Tifa doesn't represent me
Nazi sure as hell don't represent me you
know but but when we say the left or the
atheists that's sort of an over
generalization of the broad scope I
think that that maybe wait the Twitter
attacks look like to you but the loudest
ones hardly ever represent the majority
yeah no I know they don't and I just
thought I thought would be interesting
to bring it with you specifically
because I know you're very much in this
world
so you mentioned liberalism there from
everything that I pretty much know about
you you strike me as sort of an
old-school classic liberal what what
does liberal even mean to you freedom
I think Liberty I think it means doing
what's right because it's right not
because of votes or politics or pressure
and I think it just means being
reasonable and letting people have their
freedoms as long as they're not hurting
other people it's it's pretty straight
forward I think yeah which is why it's
mind-blowing to me that if I say hey
guys maybe we shouldn't punch people who
we disagree with I'm then called a Nazi
you know yesterday yeah well then you're
I see the Nazi defender just yet sir
yesterday I was a Nazi defender at the
same time someone on Twitter told me I
was way too Lefty
for them mm-hmm which like now maybe you
guys should talk and see which one of
you were right right well when you're
getting hit from both sides it usually
means you're doing something right so I
guess so I mean I just I just want
people to be reasonable that's really
all I want yeah I want people to stop
and think about what they're saying what
they're doing and and to come with
evidence that's really it
I I don't see why that's a problem for
people and then I'm called a fence
riding centrist if you got that well
I've noticed a new attack on on centrist
wait by the way I think I said classic
liberal it's obviously a classical
liberal I don't want to I don't want to
give anyone an opportunity clip
something and go he doesn't know what
he's done well anyway Ben just until at
the end of the word is an important but
I'm glad you brought that up because I
do see now a sort of new quasi
intellectual assault on the centrists
you see they're the ones that are really
creating the problem here
yep it's it's crazy if I say hey guys we
shouldn't you know if conservatives are
peacefully marching and you disagree
with them go march next to them hold up
a sign protest them but don't show up
with shields and masks and smoke bombs
and punch them let's not encourage
violence let's not do that and then and
they're like oh so you're a Nazi
sympathizer and I say well no I
definitely don't agree with Nazis I'm
far more on your side than I am Nazi
side right and I disagree with them too
but I would like to beat their ideas
with ideas not with shields and fists
can we be reasonable can we talk to them
and then they then they say oh your
fence writing yeah you just you have no
opinions on anything actually I have
opinions on both I have double-v
opinions yeah and and I think both of
you are out of your minds and I want I
want to have a call for peace and it's
crazy how much a call for peace mm-hmm
seems to ignite so much violence well
it's it's so interesting how it is
becoming politics is becoming a team
sport and now with everything that's
going on with the NFL and the anthems
and take a knee all that you see it's
politics has now reached fully into
sports like it really it's starting to
infect every facet of society I as
someone that cares about just the
general good of society I'm worried
about that that we're pinning ourselves
off everywhere there's going to be no
play
for refuge basically where are you gonna
go right to to meet a stranger I'll tell
you the romantic conversation the Reuben
report and dogma debate yeah I think
this is why our shows are gaining
popularity like the ours because people
like the long form new wants discussions
yeah and this is this is what we need is
the new ones you don't get it on CNN you
get eight seconds of how much can we
make them fight and then put up the
NASCAR commercial so that it gets the
most views there's all these sixteen box
of boxes of people screaming at each
other for ten minutes you're not gonna
walk away feeling good about not very
helpful and I got to say this team sport
thing that you know what I want to touch
on that for a second because whenever
you did your interview on Tucker Carlson
yeah about the YouTube you might have to
take I think about a month ago I I
tweeted that and immediately I started
getting hate for tweeting anything with
Tucker Carlson it yeah and then they
flipped out because you were in there
like oh wow tucker carlson and dave
rubin atheism has jumped the shark and
immediately just trash trash trash right
right literally let me nothing to do
with what we were discussing and i'm
talking seconds after i to like the the
videos a minute maybe or neither forty
seconds or so it was very short clip
really literally haven't even had time
to watch the video i never watch and
here they are just just talking trash
about the source and then probably does
that say about so one of my frustrations
i think in this has been that and again
i guess partly i guess because of the
twitter thing but I see so much
intolerance coming from the skeptic
community the atheist community so
someone like Tucker for example Tucker
who I'm sure if I was to whittle down
all of our political positions we
probably are plenty of disagreements but
I know that in the free speech battle
and in the stuff that's going on on
college campuses and all that he's been
a major ally when nobody would put him
on on MSNBC when no one would put Brett
Weinstein up from Evergreen State on
MSNBC or on CNN guess who put him on
Tucker yeah Tucker had me on to talk
about why I left the lab Tucker had me
on to talk about the YouTube stuff I
mean he's making allies in some of these
places sometimes you gotta find allies
in places that you didn't expect no no
you're spot-on and just the other day I
think rocket science he's you're
familiar with Shaun King
blacklivesmatter he tweeted something
white guy the white guy yeah about four
or five days later he tweeted something
about crime statistics that I'd never
seen before he linked to
like the Department of Justice and I
went oh that's great people need to see
this
so I retweeted Shaun King and oh the
flood from the other side was like I
can't believe you're retweeting that sjw
snowflake I'm like it's not about who he
is it's about the content he's sharing
and then just a few days later I shared
something from Beverly Hills and Tifa
which is an NTFS poof sighs yeah
but they had a real video right of an
actual water if you saw it of the the
woman that they I believe she's Hispanic
yelling at the white and Tifa kids oh I
did see the like you're not hearing a
racist your wife he's like I'm punching
Nazis and she's like you don't just
punch and shut up quit talking to them
and punch them and she's like it's just
it's just weird inside of and so I
tweeted that and said isn't Aoife now
eating their own like is this what's
happening and then I I started getting
so much flack for for tweeting Beverly
Hills aunt Eva they just focused on the
the source I'm like did you watch the
video yeah it I don't understand this
team sport I can't share Carson and Cher
Shaun King and then share Beverly Hills
and Tifa no no no I I'm not allowed to
do that do you think that the people
that actually care about buildings and
bridges care about tolerance and
liberalism and all of those things do
you think in a weird way we're the least
positioned to win this fight like we've
got the hysterics on both sides right so
there's an authoritarian part of the
left obviously there's an authoritarian
part of the right now you have this I do
see a growing group of people right with
what we're doing right now but that
because we're trying to use logic and
reason we're not trying to rip everybody
apart we don't go after motives and
motivation we don't do personal attacks
all those things that in a weird way
we're not set up to fight the way people
fight these days that's a good point and
I think if we lose this
if we lose ground it's it's gonna be
because of the silent majority I think
it's one of these weird situations where
the majority of people listen to us and
go yeah I'm right on board with that but
they don't want to speak up because who
wants to be known as a Dave Rubin
supporter if all of your friends are
extreme left and who wants to say David
Smalley has a point because all the crap
I got for retweeting Shaun King yeah if
he tweets something else I'll go
is it worth it you'll hesitate even
though he has good stuff I'm like is it
worth it or if I see something from
Beverly Hills antifa ago is it worth it
the content stands alone but they're not
even gonna pay attention to the content
so me I intentionally force myself to do
it because I think we deserve to win the
fight but I could see a lot of people
out there that are the silent majority
going I totally agree with that I'm just
not gonna click like or the heart
because I don't want to be labeled as
that Nazi sympathizer by the way to
really drive your point home you know if
I had seen that you had retweeted Shawn
King I probably would have rolled my
eyes
even if it really a study that was a
even if it was Twitter totally just said
yeah I think I think he's just such a
fraud man and a bad player in in this
issue I don't know yeah yeah but I
probably my own self I probably even
knowing you I would have been like why'd
Smalley bother doing that so we all we
all have our week it's good to take
notice of that and to take your
inventory and go is that the logical way
to go let me look judge the content on
its own
don't just discount it because of who
shared it so all the center you
disappointed with the amount of sort of
players that we have right now I feel
like I could count on probably maybe
need four hands to get like the people
that are really trying to cut through
some of the [ __ ]
we need more I don't know where they are
I'm trying to find them they're there
they're just being silent and there's a
lot to lose I mean if for example in my
situation I built my show over about
about five years with a certain base a
certain audience that audience drives
depending on how many downloads we get
that's how the advertisers have to
choose how much they're paying for know
so that's all financially tied and then
you have the the private stuff like the
private membership stuff the the patreon
type platform all that all that's tied
together and so once you do that
full-time you know as your job and then
you mention something like you know
maybe Tucker Carlson had a point on this
or maybe and then you're labeled a Nazi
and then you see something happen on
your social media you go oh my gosh like
that's that's a scary thought that's why
we most of the people we see speaking up
are professors yeah they have their own
full-time jobs right and this is just a
side thing that they're doing so I think
if it wasn't so volatile you know more
people would do it people like you and I
are just willing to take the risk
we're willing to go this is the this is
my opinion and and if people don't want
to support it don't support it you can
always turn it off you can always
unsubscribe are you amazed by those
people who are screaming all day long
I'm always like if someone forcing you
to watch this say you are right yeah an
Indian held hostage I'll call somebody
yeah you'll get a complete refund on the
free show you guys watch online yeah
that's that's it's amazing to me that
they will demand change refuse to
support and then when you say well if
you sign up you'll get it with no ads or
you'll get extra bonus you should give
that for free too well that costs money
do you want to support the show Wow
can't believe you're asking for cash
you're all about the money it's crazy
it's like you know if someone came to
your job and tried to force you to do it
for free how would you feel about it you
know I kind of want to film this spoof
video where I just go around to movie
theaters and going like two tickets to
Spider Man and they go that'll be 1850
you're charging how dare you put that
behind a paywall I want to lose my mind
and and show that you know this is how
people make a living and so I think a
lot of people are afraid because they're
they're they're bottom dollar is
connected to that they're scared to
speak up I've seen a dip in my income
when I will say something bad about
antifa but I'll just nothing bad about
him just disagree and go guys this isn't
the way forward I'll see a dip in my
downloads I'll see a dip in people not
wanting to support me and I go I don't
want the support of people who think
punching folks is the nice way to move
forward is the best way to move forward
I don't want their support but I do need
to live so I understand why some people
are more hesitant I'm just gonna keep
moving forward regardless of how many
people are supporting it because one
thing my mom did teach me all my life is
do what's right because it's the right
thing to do not because of reward or not
because you're scared of punishment do
right because it's the right thing to do
period no religion necessary just do
right and I don't think punching people
we disagree with is right no matter how
vile and disgusting their opinions are
I'm gonna stick to that yeah yeah you
know I feel the same way it's like I'm
just doing what I think is right that
really is it if I whittled down every
other factor that's going on here every
other business decision I'm doing what I
think is right
there have been many times that has been
at my own financial cost but I'm willing
to do that because I can survive and
figure out what to do you've had an
interesting political evolution too
because I think it's sort of similar to
what I you you were you're you were a
lefty I don't know what do you what do
you consider yourself now I think I
would say I would say I'm left-of-centre
yeah I still consider myself part of the
left but I'm what does that mean I don't
know I would say that I'm a liberal I
had Adam Carolla on my show and I was
shocked at how much stuff we agreed on
he called himself a liberal and I went I
kind of joked with him about what I said
you know I really heard you were a
conservative shill and he's like well
let's go down the list yeah support gay
marriage I think you know pot should be
legal I think you know whatever you do
in your home should be up to you I don't
think the government should come in and
tell you who to have sex with or what to
put in your body
it's very I'm like no I'm not
disagreeing with any of that the
religious right who wants to teach you
know Bible study in schools and that's
the the opposite of me I'm not I'm not a
conservative I think Betsy DeVos is one
of the worst thing that's ever happened
to our education system most of trumps
appointments disturbed me to a huge
level there they're the right-wing sort
of if if you're an atheist we don't want
you if you're Jewish we don't want you
this is a Christian nation like it or
get out
that's the religious right that I would
say I'm left of right but when it comes
to you know most political ideas I would
say I'm liberal and that's why when you
say I left the left I go I think I think
the left is leaving us well yeah I think
there's a liberal and I think I'm still
a liberal and I think if if an Tifa is
the new left then I'm I'm being forced
to be called Center but I didn't move
yeah I'm still I feel like I'm still as
reasonable as I was three years ago but
if if the left is going off to say the
new left is to punch a Nazi yeah I'm not
there right and that that's really where
I'm at because to me and I've said this
many times that defending my liberal
principles is becoming a conservative
position you know what I mean like the
the liberal things that you believe in
that's actually being defended by
today's conservatives by most
estimations Carolla is really a
conservative but yeah he's defending
those those basic liberal things where
unfortunately what's happening with the
left it to me it's being led by its
worst pieces so that a Linda Sarsour is
the type of person that bernie is out
there defending yeah and that was so
who's the leader of the left now you can
say the same thing about Trump but
ironically with Trump he's not really in
bed with the the Christian conservatives
so it's a little harder to figure out
even though they voted for him at a very
high level
yeah he's obviously not one of them well
the interesting thing about that point
is that I don't think maybe it's just a
match made in hell and that's much worse
actually well it's it's to me it's more
of an idea that conservatives and I've
always had this problem of conservatives
that they don't tend to actually espouse
what are supposed to be conservative
views meaning we're for small government
yeah okay until a woman wants to make
decisions about her own body then they
want to come into her bedroom and tell
her and her doctor and say you're not
allowed to do this or you must have us
what's it called the the internal
sonogram thing where they go in
enforcing a woman to be penetrated with
a machine before she can have abortion
because they want her to hear the
heartbeat of and it's all this can you
support this yeah you the guy of small
government oh and then gay marriage I
I'm a married straight white male who's
conservative but you two guys get in
there and somehow affects me so I'm
gonna stop you from doing it they don't
seem to really act the way they say they
act yeah I would be for small government
for the most part but we do need some
government positions I think we should
have some sort of single-payer health
care system I think we should have some
sort of I mean I wouldn't necessarily be
against the flat tax I had a really
close friend of mine who was a financial
expert come on my show and sort of
proved to me that was a bad idea but he
said it could be done but it was sort of
about it and I went okay that makes
sense I can wait for a fly attack but
what are the evidence leads I'm that's
where I'm gonna go so when I say I'm
left-of-center it's really the religious
right it's the Pat Robertson it's the
Glenn Beck it's the Donald Trump the
Steve ban and those are the guys that I
say I'm definitely left of that butt and
my Linda Sarsour
absolutely yeah and I don't know where I
am on the scale call me a centrist I
don't know I just I think Pat Robertson
and Linda Sarsour have some similar
issues yeah yeah yes it's the horseshoe
theory of at some point they're sharing
the same delusion it's interesting cuz I
don't want to go too far down that
rabbit hole cuz I dunno how you feel
about all the labels and all that stuff
and I obviously feel Ennis I feel
similarly but I think it's important
because it shows to discuss it it shows
for the audience they can go alright
well to people who are in it who are
living this we talk about this stuff are
at the same time trying to play it out
yeah themselves and while everyone else
is just screaming this is what I am this
is what you are that the average person
just isn't and that's what I'm trying to
that's the silent majority
that's a silent majority and I think a
lot of times and I've fall into this
trouble as well I'll say the left now
the left is and I'm talking about the
screeching you know the people at the
University yelling at the professor
saying put your hands down that's a
microaggression then he puts his hands
down and they laugh at in that that if
I'm if I'm going on the Left which is
why I've had to be careful about it
because most of my friends and I would
even consider you sort of still in that
that liberal section of technically I
think you are center or left of center I
don't think you agree with the most of
the religious right of the Pat
Robertson's of the Glenn Beck's you
agree more with people in the center or
liberal yeah I I would split Glenn and
Pat Robertson both that that's a whole
thing to do Glenn I think it's much more
of an actual libertarian who God he's
gotten sort of lost up in some of the
religious stuff but I actually from from
at least my conversation with him I
sense that the libertarianism and the
small government stuff was starting to
override some of the religious you're
right so I'm level you're right by the
way not in all levels cuz look what
happened with him and Tommy Lera and
over abortion so right exactly and by
the way that's another guy I would love
to have on my show yeah Glenn Beck I
think it'd be a perfect fit for me I
think you guys would have just get out
your rolodex and let's see what
everybody gets just call them right now
may get em back yes so yeah so I I think
sometimes we make the mistake of saying
the left and dennis prager will do and
say the left and then adam carolla gets
on his younger the problem with the left
and then people
like me feel disenfranchised by you and
dennis prager and i guys you're calling
us and Tifa we disagree with them too
which then makes us turn to aunty fun go
dude what the hell why are you acting
like this you're making liberals look
crazy and they're going here a Nazi
supporting conservative and so there's
this infighting going on and I'm like
wait a minute come out Donald Trump got
elected president the right should be
eating itself we should be sitting back
uniting and going let's watch the
Republicans sort of eat their own and
then this idea si Republicans hardcore
right-wing conservatives like Steve
Bannon and Donald Trump and you know
those guys let's let them collapse and
then go in there and be reasonable
classical liberals and and and put
things back where they should be but we
can't now because folks like Ann Tifa
are using fascism to prove that fascism
doesn't work with their violence and
control and it's it's sort of like we're
becoming this this parody of ourselves
and in the moment when we had that
moment this was our moment Donald Trump
being elected is the lowest the
Republican Party has ever been they're
fighting each other they don't like him
this is our opportunity to seize control
and we are we're wasting it on
infighting yeah and I actually think the
ship has sailed I thought I did think
and I'm 99% sure I said this right after
the election I thought there was going
to be a period of the left going alright
let's figure did we miss something did
we put too much on identity politics did
we focus the wrong way all of that and
yet I've seen virtually and now when I
save the left I'm talking about the
mainstream left so the leadership of the
party know so I'm talking about Bernie
and Ellison and Perez and their ISM that
they've all doubled down on all of those
things so that's a case where I do say
the left and I'm not talking about an
Tifa okay that the mainstream modern
left loves identity politics the thing
that I think will could potentially
destroy this country is what they're
playing it now people will listen to
that and go wow you see he's defending
Trump that I did not say Trump no and I
think I think in that situation those
those are politicians that who are
terrified of losing their base when I
talk about downloads or patreon or
worried about
losing funding that's nothing compared
to a politician losing votes yeah so but
I think that's the that's the
unfortunate part about it yeah do you
how passionate are you about politics in
the first place pretty passionate I do a
lot of my shows about politics a lot of
my shows are we will pull up sort of
these types of these types of issues and
talk about them I sort of split my show
into two sometimes I'll have on a
Christian it will just be a long
conversation of me talking about the
Bible and then the next episode maybe me
just you know with three or four
different people hashing out political
ideas like this so yeah do you find it
easier right now to build bridges to the
right I mean I know you've had Dennis
Prager on we've had a bunch of similar
guests absolutely yeah absolutely and
and that's where the left gets mad at me
and they go I he's becoming he's he's
becoming just like Dave Rubin here's
that here's the thing I didn't know
maybe so many people were angry at me
but these that well they're they I get a
lot of it because they know that I know
you and they feel like you're probably
unreachable and they can reach me now
they go hey Reuben Ron it's stupid beard
and yeah I'm just saying they're angry
at you and you got a beard and became
Moses and now he's a Jesus loving cult
leader and that's that's who you've
become so you wish that you could be as
sort of calculating or as influential as
people think that you are you know
really great like what I saw people
saying all the [ __ ] about me I'm like
man that is so it's so not even in the
realm of truth I'm not just talking
about like what they're saying just
everything that you think about how I do
things or why I do things none of it has
any bearing on reality no no no it's
this it's this this idea of what they
think you've become yeah and they fight
against that and then I'm telling you
I've said multiple times I'm like guys
it's really sad yeah when I can sit down
with a Christian in my studio who looks
across from me and says you have no
basis for morality and I respond with I
understand you feel that way and I know
you have a religious belief that tells
you that let me tell you my objective
moral standard and how I got there
without religion and we have a cordial
conversation of them telling me I have
no morality and I'm telling them they
believe in a delusion but we're doing it
in a respectful way but the atheist
Facebook are being total dicks to me and
I'm like guys there's something wrong
with our community if I can have cordial
conversations with conservatives and
with Christians and atheists are trying
to eat me alive
something's not right these are these
are political differences and it used to
be and I'll tell you I've been in this
movement eight or nine years in almost
ten years I'm telling you it used to be
that the Christians were the nope God is
real if you don't like it get out they
didn't want to have the discussion in
the Atheist community all agreed on can
we just walk can I just tell you my
differing views can I can we disagree
and still get along can we just talk
about it and now it's like it's turning
the other way around the Christians are
like sure I'll talk to you and the only
the other atheists go yeah but did you
tweet Tucker Carlson well then I hate
you flock David's a Nazi you know it's
funny you'll love this one so I had
Bishop Baron on have you chatted with
him you know I have no ok so you've had
him Travis yeah so Baron is he's from
the archdiocese here in LA when we had
him on I don't think he did I know for a
fact now that he did not know that I was
gay he knew this was a home studio but
we talked about you know about gay
marriage and a bunch of other stuff and
he never you know people were angry at
me like how could you even bring him
into your house so I had people these
are this is sort of the left in the
atheist me like I didn't even sit down
yeah but ironically that wasn't the most
interesting part the most interesting
part to me was that he told me or his
people told us after the amount of hate
he was getting from right-wing people
saying how could you sit down with Dave
and that's when I was like man this is
without question the right thing to do
because we sat here did I think that I
was gonna sit across from a guy that
could be the Pope one day or something
whose very influential in the Catholic
Church and get him to be like oh my god
I'm forgave my rage like of course of
course not but I thought I can do is
show him a human with with a mind and
some arguments and by the way I was a
little more even though at none of his
arguments changed my beliefs on anything
it was nice to just hear someone say
what they think even if I even if I saw
the flaws in the argument but I thought
the way that we each get hate I just
thought it was particularly interesting
something happened similar with Brian
Fisher he came on my show
people know Brian Fisher has just this
monster who he says things like the the
gay Gestapo and every time he mentions
gays he talks about HIV and he talks
about he throw the Bible calls them
beasts for a read those aren't my words
that's the Bible he says some pretty
vile things but when I had him on I went
you're a grandpa right yeah you have a
master's degree from Stanford yeah what
are your grandkids call you
papaw or what I want to show a human
element and then go Brian you know when
you say things like gay Gestapo you
really hurt people you don't seem like
the kind of guy that want to hurt people
why do you want to hurt people and of
course he gets crap for going on the
atheist show and and I get it for you no
I catch a lot of [ __ ] from Christians
going I can't believe you gave that guy
a platform but I'm like I think Brian
Fisher has plenty of a platform if he
wants it my shows about dialogue and
tackling tough ideas with respect that
that's all I ever want to be about and
you know what if you don't like that
stop listening I don't I don't maybe
that's what my downloads go down I tell
them this cuz every show is stuff I
remember you were like thanks Gabe for
coming on and for you guys stop let's
stop listening to this [ __ ] what is
wrong with you that's not I say at the
end of every show so you mentioned sort
of a little bit of the the intolerance
or the shift that you've seen in the
Atheist community and I wasn't involved
in it for that long but I've seen a
little bit of that a sense of that as
well do you think when I don't know how
familiar you are with the arguments of
Jordan Peterson but but sort of the
basic arguments that the Atheist
community or the secular community at
large it's missing something to unite it
like it's missing the grandiose stories
that actually transcend just sort of the
literal world in front of us you know
and that's why you know Briggs it for me
this isn't what he says but like Star
Wars has meaning to me and I've learned
some truths out of Star Wars and some
ideas that aren't just the little little
secular world ideas you know
yeah he'll tell you that you know he
references the story of Pinocchio
right or or biblical stories also and he
is Christian so I'm gonna I'm gonna put
out a new idea here right now and I'm
gonna change what I've been saying I'm
going off-script is that okay
this whole time I've been reading it
doctor yeah I've been reading that I was
saying everything he wanted me to say
right now I'm not gonna say it
first of all Jordan Peterson he's he
said he's gonna come on my show at the
after the end of the year nice there so
sometimes January February I hope to
have in my studio or at least on skype
or something
but um I've been sort of this this
activist within the activist community
saying guys let's not kill the atheist
community let's not kill the secular
movement and anytime you call for peace
which is what my Christian guest told me
just last night anytime you call for
peace you tend to be the target of
violence and the target of hate at the
very least and that's what's happened
when I go hey Nazis you know you should
probably do a DNA test it's silly for
you to think you have pure anything
white people are definitely not 100
percent homo sapien we've got something
else in us just do a test you have
nothing to be proud of and then and then
on the other side it's um
hey maybe we shouldn't punch the people
who are wrong about DNA maybe we should
just say hey guys here's a DNA test or
here's some some data and try to find a
reasonable one in the group that you can
just change that one person's mind I'm
not saying they're lighting crosses on
fire and you're trying to show them
science and that's not what I'm saying
I get the need for protest I get the
need for civil disobedience I understand
it's it's effective but when you say
maybe we shouldn't hit them you know
then then you get attacked but I'll say
this I think the mistake is and the
mistake that I've been making I just
released a YouTube video called eating
our own how you can save the atheist
movement and it's actually a friend of
mine Seth Andrews did it on his channel
the thinking atheist YouTube channel and
so he he put the video out and so I sort
of just months ago I put out this idea
we should save our movement and I'm
gonna I'm gonna change that now because
you mentioned this I'm answering your
question I know this is a long way no no
I'm with the the answer is I think the
mistake is thinking that we that we need
to be United
atheists atheism isn't a religion we
have no rituals we have no beliefs we
have no set or guideline you need to
follow it's simply the movement itself
is simply at its core about the
separation of church and state that's it
a secular Coalition for America
wonderful organization they come on my
show all the time they go Lobby US
Congress in DC for laws and for hey
maybe it's gonna be sex education it
should be science-based
let's get rid of abstinence only it
doesn't work here are the stats that's
what they do that's what the Atheist
community is actually about but due to
identity politics intersectionality now
it's become about these conferences end
up being completely social justice
oriented that's fine if you want to have
a social justice conference do that yeah
but don't call it an atheist conference
and then make it all about social
justice right so I think the more we try
to unite on certain issues the more we
find differences and reasons to divide
so for me it's about just backing out of
it and going guys there's only one thing
we agree on that we don't see enough
evidence for a god and that our
government shouldn't take sides so how
about we just back up stop this stop
drilling down into specific issues back
up and say if I can find an ally in
Dennis Prager or in Adam Carolla
or in Tucker Carlson or in Vinci pro2
say yeah maybe we shouldn't teach
religion shouldn't teach Bible study in
public school and maybe the Ten
Commandment shouldn't be at the
courthouse why not reach across that
aisle and embrace that ally ship because
that's what it's about the more we try
to force people to unite over identity
politics and intersectionality the more
we're eating our own so I think that the
issue is we don't we have the theme
already and we've tried to
overcomplicate it
yeah it's a great answer you know when I
was at the reason rally were you there
last year I met you at the reason rally
Dave you told me that thank you Matt a
lobby boy yep that's okay so I
understood I'm not drinking a lot I was
around No okay we did be there so but do
you remember there was this whole
controversy about the about that they
didn't want certain speakers and people
angry at everybody in deep platforming
people and I remember
all these people were fighting in there
they said they were in enough there was
enough diversity and all this stuff and
I remember all these people fighting and
people kept saying Dave what are you
gonna say about all those above and I
went up there and I gave my speech and I
gave it exactly as I planned and I said
to everybody I just really I took it
didn't even know you were gonna say the
six months later but but I took
basically what you just said there said
let's continue being the tolerant people
let's not be the ones that deep platform
let's do all these things I don't know
if I guess didn't totally don't worry
Dave but you know you know it's
interesting how deep all of this goes
because so so Dawkins I interviewed last
month it was one of the the greatest
moments of my professional career
certainly you've interviewed him he's
funny people so funny I mean there were
you know I think comedian like I was
actually doing comedy at the reason
rally I put myself out there as a comic
I do go out of here in LA all the time
yeah I don't think of Dawkins as a
comedian but he's hilarious
yeah why don't we shoot why don't we do
a stand-up show together something I was
sort of getting back in a little heavy
yeah I'd Richard Lewis on last week now
it's like really kind of I've got a
bouncing back in a little bit but I need
like something to click so I have a
solid ten I can do it right now we can I
can do it right now I used to have a
messy 45 ugly thirty and I got it we
should do something right we'll talk
about that but but one thing that I
think shows how sort of pervasive that
the SJW stuff is is that so I
interviewed Dawkins and he spent a
decent amount of time talking about what
he thought was wrong with the Trump
supporters and all that and I think in
and of itself that's fine but what hit
me was those are not the people trying
to deep LAT form him and I thought it
was a really interesting thing so like
he has a frustration with these type of
people who voted for Trump okay I get it
there's obviously an anti-science bent
to a lot of people in that crew and
certainly to summit Trump's appointments
and all that without question but I
thought that he was focusing on them
instead of the people who were actually
out there trying to deep LAT form him
and get him off you know atheist panels
and to speak at universities I heard it
it shows how even the smartest of us you
know and I consider this guy like at the
top of that thing you know he's right
there ain't the top that we all sort of
aim our fire in weird ways that doesn't
make sense all the time yeah does that
drive at you yeah for sure yeah I'm
I'm right there with you and I what I
talked to him we specifically talked
about how he is avoiding certain topics
now because I said what one of my course
was what can we do in in our part of the
world to help the Muslim countries that
are oppressing women from driving and
all these other things and he's like
David I I tried once and they were like
how dare you tell this culture what's
better for them and he's like I'm asking
for equality he's like and I just got so
much so I'm like I'm not gonna do it so
he tries to aim it and then even that it
redirected think how think how scary
that proposition though is if a guy like
Dawkins who we have nothing but love and
admiration for if he has to feel that he
has to shift a little bit because he
doesn't want to deal with far we
certainly know about Sam Harris and
plenty of the others but then you can
see why these conversations never really
happen because every people are just
people at the end of the day like
everyone can deal with a certain amount
of heat and then I think that's why
actually very early in might within ten
minutes of the sit down with Dawkins it
was obvious to me he wanted to do
science and I pretty much shelved all
the religious stuff and I was like you
know what let's the book is called
science in the soul that that's what
we're gonna talk about interesting words
soul for a you know for a non-believer
to use but that we all we all can only
take so much heat even the best of us
yeah and I I found because I was sort of
getting into this idea of trying to
respond to the trolls and go guys that's
not what I said but I didn't say that
and at one point I just I think I put on
Facebook Facebook should really create
an emoji for I didn't say that that
would save us a lot of time because I
you know this this basic this basic
concept what's called Rappaport's rules
if you can't clearly state your your
opposition's position back to them yeah
in a way that they would agree and say
that's exactly what I mean you're not
ready to form an argument against it but
so many people on social media will go
on this attack not even understanding so
so he'll make a statement and then
immediately there's hate and he's like
he has to spend the next 20 minutes
going I didn't say that I didn't say
that in one point I've seen him say if
you think that's what I said you need to
go away and learn how to think
he just gets so frustrated but the idea
that the idea that someone of Richard
Dawkins intellect is dealing with the
anonymous troll is is so it's such a
mind warp really and you know it's funny
because throughout this there's been
this theme about what's happening on
social media and how they're affecting
people and all that and I always feel
what I'm talking about it it's either a
little too inside or baseball or yeah
we're focusing on it in a way that maybe
the audience is it and they're gonna
know we're getting to them you know you
know what though
I actually think that a lot of this [ __ ]
is now leaking into reality yeah it is
and that's why I think it's worth
talking about because all of those
conversations that used to just exist
online are now leaking out into reality
everywhere from from Trump to to NFL
athletes to everywhere so it's like we
can't ignore it even though it's Oh
frustrating
my wife Brandi she posted the other day
she saw for the first time a lamborghini
aventador she saw it in LA okay she came
home and she's like honey I fell in love
with the sexiest car I'm gonna leave you
for this car if it ever lets me like
this things I may like what was it she
described and I said that sounds like a
Lamborghini Aventador and I googled it
pulled it up she's like that's it and I
was pretty proud of myself based on the
sound and the description I was like I
think I got it and she we both fell in
love so we've been watching videos about
another thing so she posts it on
Facebook oh this picture of this car and
goes I love this car I it's absolutely
beautiful one of the first comments
should we really love now there are a
lot of people out there that need love
you know people there's a lot more
things you could spend money on other
than a damn Lamborghini and it just
happened nothing nothing religious-based
nothing politics based just just people
at home just going I have an opinion on
your life yeah you know it's just and so
you're right it's it I think a lot of
people can relate to it even if they're
not content creators you just put
something out there people just they
just inherently want to [ __ ] on it and I
don't know why I don't I don't think
it's gotten very easy it's so easy I
have a really good friend who said you
know those those people in the back of
the class that never used to say
anything now they have a megaphone yeah
and this I got my opinions you know and
and so I don't I don't ever want to
prevent someone from speaking up I want
people to to talk and have their
opinions heard which I think social
media
be a wonderful tool for that because the
guy at the back of the class sometimes
has the best idea he's just quiet and
shy and now he gets to express himself
it can be good but when those people
turn into vile trolls and say their goal
is to take down the mighty Richard
Dawkins and just try to call him out for
every little thing on some level they
think they're equating themselves to him
and like now you're fighting Mike I
don't know if you were like this when I
was a kid the big thing was would you
get in the ring with Mike Tyson three
million dollars for 30 seconds would you
that was our fear like winter marries
Pink's regrets it yeah Larry Michael
spanks Michael Spinks Spinks Larry who
was the Larry
now with the Holmes Larry Holmes Larry
Holmes I combined them into one duper
boxer who probably got knocked out in
six seconds they would probably get by
Tyson yeah but that was our big thing we
weren't afraid of Mike Tyson and so now
it's on this way where you can you can
go toe-to-toe with the Tyson of our day
yeah from the safety of your home and
then there's this weird part where
sometimes I'll respond to someone and
they'll be like um thank you for even
responding I don't realize you're like
wait a minute you just wanted me to show
attention like that's on my level I know
what happens later on your level and on
a monumental exponentially higher level
on Richard Dawkins Apple I'm like I
wonder if half these people are just
trying to get his attention to get him
to respond because you know maybe a spat
on the nose is better than being ignored
right in some weird way and if they're
just like I like you or thank you you're
like whatever yeah like yeah then it
gets the attention and it's sad it's
really sad because I think it's pushing
public intellectuals a wave yeah from
commuting from communicating with with
people and me being in a position where
I have a platform I want to get better
at what I do well how do I get better by
getting criticism I want to take in the
criticism go wow they didn't like that I
only did a 90-minute show they like my
shows being three hours I'll go back to
that if I don't pay attention I don't
know what you like but then again
sometimes when I pay attention I get
bogged down in these more rabbit-hole
fights that are senseless so people like
sam harris people like richard dawkins
lawrence krauss adam carolla they just
don't look at it they just walk away
from twitter and then you're you're now
losing it in a pot of
a potential positive interaction with
someone yeah and so I don't get the idea
of being nasty you you'll get much
further if you try to emulate the
behaviors that you see and grow your own
audience and that person will eventually
respect you as a peer not attacking them
they're never gonna respond and then my
favorite thing is they don't respond
because they know I'm right dave rubin
can't handle me he won't respond because
i own his ass yeah friend of mine told
me that about sam harris he doesn't
respond to me cuz i own is that that's
no way yeah that's it he's terrified to
talk to you that's hilarious I was at a
we gotta wrap this up but I was at a
talk a couple months back with it was
Sam interviewing Dawkins oh la was
awesome and this guy comes up at the end
you know they do the Q&A and the guy
comes up and he's like I know the - you
won't fully be able to understand this
but I've been like right into some like
just some insane you know question about
whatever but I just thought wow what a
funny way to present some well arrogant
I got some knowledge bear with me while
I talk to you I know Richard Dawkins and
sam Harris you won't be able to
comprehend what I'm about to say crazy -
those two guys - yeah all right well I
think the main takeaway here is that I'm
going to keep trying to fight this the
right way as long as you will keep
trying to fight it the right way look
and give a little space for some of
those public intellectuals - to do the
things that are gonna make us look
smarter happen let's let's do it let's
do it let's continue the conversation
and embrace the nuance that's what's
missing right now embrace the new ones
all right and you know what I will
commit right now while this is being
recorded - doing some sort of stand-up
thing with you in LA or the next month
or - let's let's add something okay
well set it up all right for more on
David check out the dogma debate podcast
at Dogma debate
[Music]
you